[Music]
those who look for the bad in people
will surely find it
[Music]
when i do good i feel good when i do bad
i feel bad that's my religion
[Music]
when you reach the end of your rope tie
a knot and hang on
[Music]
i am a slow walker but i never walk back
the best way to predict your future is
to create it
[Music]
that some achieve great success is proof
to all that others can achieve it as
well
[Music]
my concern is not whether god is on our
side my greatest concern is to be on
god's side for god is always right
[Music]
i would rather be a little nobody than
to be an evil somebody
[Music]
character is like a tree and reputation
its shadow the shadow is what we think
it is and the tree is the real thing
most folks are about as happy as they
make their minds up to be
[Music]
tact
the ability to describe others as they
see themselves
[Music]
i do the very best i know how the very
best i can and i mean to keep on doing
so until the end
[Music]
he has a right to criticize who has a
heart to help
i have always found that mercy bears
richer fruits than strict justice
[Music]
no man has a good enough memory to be a
successful liar
human action can be modified to some
extent but human nature cannot be
changed
those who deny freedom to others deserve
it not for themselves
[Music]
government of the people by the people
for the people shall not perish from the
earth
[Music]
no man is good enough to govern another
man without the other's consent
[Music]
as i would not be a slave so i would not
be a master
this expresses my idea of democracy
[Music]
money will cease to be master and become
the servant of humanity
democracy will rise superior to the
money power
[Music]
i am in favor of animal rights as well
as human rights
that is the way of a whole human being
[Music]
what i want is to get done what the
people desire to have done and the
question for me is how to find that out
exactly
[Music]
whenever i hear anyone arguing for
slavery i feel a strong impulse to see
it tried on him personally
[Music]
you have to do your own growing no
matter how tall your grandfather was
[Music]
whatever you are be a good one
nearly all men can stand adversity but
if you want to test a man's character
give him power
[Music]
always bear in mind that your own
resolution to success is more important
than any other thing
i don't like that man i must get to know
him better
[Music]
leave nothing for tomorrow which can be
done today
things may come to those who wait but
only the things left by those who hustle
[Music]
be sure you put your feet in the right
place then stand firm
[Music]
my great concern is not whether you have
failed but whether you are content with
your failure
[Music]
give me six hours to chop down a tree
and i will spend the first four
sharpening the x
[Music]
you cannot escape the responsibility of
tomorrow by evading it today
[Music]
there are no bad pictures that's just
how your face looks sometimes
[Music]
common looking people are the best in
the world that is the reason the lord
makes so many of them
[Music]
better to remain silent and be thought a
fool than to speak out and remove all
doubt
[Music]
if i were two-faced would i be showing
you this one
[Music]
no matter how much cats fight there
always seems to be plenty of kittens
if you call a dog's tail a leg how many
legs does it have four because calling a
tail a leg doesn't make it one
[Music]
it has been my experience that folks who
have no vices have very few virtues
[Music]
i will prepare and someday my chance
will come
[Music]
that everyone may receive at least a
moderate education appears to be an
objective of vital importance
[Music]
the most pleasant thing for a woman is
wait for her lover knowing for sure that
he will come
[Music]
every head should be cultivated
[Music]
the philosophy of the school room in one
generation will be the philosophy of
government in the next
[Music]
all i have learned i learned from books
[Music]
i'm a success today because i had a
friend who believed in me and i didn't
have the heart to let him down
[Music]
we the people are the rightful masters
of both congress and the courts not to
overthrow the constitution but to
overthrow the men who pervert the
constitution
[Music]
you